i'm gonna start with the most important
question
uh when did you decide that you wanted
to own july
with old and pig i decided about eight
years ago that
in 2021 i was gonna own july and i just
said i'm going to have these two maybe
i'm just kidding i have no planning it's
just really
luck it's really exciting and they're
both movies that
mean a lot to me and they couldn't be
more different characters so i feel
really lucky
um that i that i got to have this
experience of having these two movies
come out at the same time
um around the same time um hopefully
people see them both and they don't get
too
sick of seeing my stupid mug on the
screen i really enjoyed pig and i really
enjoyed
old so thank you so much i'm just gonna
say uh congrats on being part of two
really good movies
thank you so much so much that's so nice
uh
yeah so i uh a lot of
go ahead questions quick though what the
hell was it like working with nick cage
in pig and i know this is about old but
like as a huge fan of cage i just have
to know
what the hell was that like he's been my
favorite actor since i was a kid when i
when the trailer came out for pig i got
messages from everybody that i've ever
known
saying hey is this a joke did you will
this into existence because
i'd been talking about how i mean he
and i feel like a lot of people tend to
say this after they work with people and
it always irritates me but
nick knows that he really was like one
of the main reasons i got into acting
was like
i just remember as a kid seeing the
family man and thinking
it was the most brilliant performance
the way he
molded that whole story and then i just
saw everything that he
and adaptation just changed my life and
leaving las vegas and
um so nick is my number one favorite
actor
you know i think he's just up there with
just nicholson and
and de niro and and like i think he's he
could be in the category of like liv
ullmann and
and um you know people from these
foreign movies and
um so i i just adore him and also he's
become
really one of my best friends on the
planet like um
you know i'm i'm ready to go to his big
wedding
in japan and and uh whenever that's
going to be and he'll be
the groomsman my wedding if i ever get
married
[Music]
he's just one of these guys we talk a
few times a week and and
um we were when we started working
together we were both
uh going through a similar time in our
lives and kind of confided in each other
and just
got attached to the hip and i feel
really really lucky to know him he's an
incredible
incredible artist more than a movie star
he's an artist and he's a
special special person it could choke me
up talking about it i just
i just i love him so much i i r he means
so much to me
listen first of all that's awesome
second of all uh i can talk about nick
the rest of the time but let's jump into
uh why i actually get a long answer but
it's nick no no no please i i
really i could talk about nick the whole
time but so one of the things
i listen i'm a big fan of of knights
movies what do you think might surprise
people to learn
about the making of an m night film
well i think everything about this movie
will surprise people but i
i'd say that everybody would be
surprised by
first of all what a nice guy he is and
and
um i think they're surprised that this
movie is really approached like it's a
drama
and i think that that is what the movie
more is is a
is sort of a psychological philosophical
allegorical drama movie that that that
gets very thrilling as it goes along
so i think um people should go in
expecting
to be haunted but in a more deep
existential way than than just some
jump scares sure i actually woke up
this morning thinking about the movie
and that doesn't happen with me that
often
uh what was your reaction it's one of
those you know like
i was waking up thinking about it for
like six months i mean
like when i first read the script before
i even knew i had the part i was
um waking up and and dreaming about it
and
thinking about it and being scared um of
getting older and and being scared
facing my past and i just think it's an
incredible
idea and an incredible delivery this is
his first time not shooting in
philadelphia
so what was it like actually being with
him outside of his comfort zone
i think it's it's hugely metaphorical
for how the movie
is i think that the movie is in some
ways out of his comfort zone i think
it's
i think it i think all his movies are
really deep and all of them are really
approach some larger concept and they're
all really scary but i believe this
movie goes deeper i think this movie is
the deepest movies ever made
i call it a bergman blockbuster and
that's what he calls it too it's kind of
like
you know it has echoes of persona and
echoes of
you know exterminating angels and i
think it's uh
just very exciting and a new chapter
for him this is an interesting
performance because you're essentially
playing a kid
uh i'm curious how do you get ready for
playing a role like this
i mean i'm already such a rambunctious
guy so
you know i think i did a lot a lot a lot
of research in terms of like reading
piaget and reading bruno betleheim and
reading a lot about child psychology
and just even um reading just
about how displacement and things and
and how kids see visually things are
different and how
that's kind of why they place their body
in weird places and
and reading about all that was very
helpful but even more than that i felt i
had to
i had to really face my fears of of how
i was as a kid and i had to really
look at myself and um deal with the
parts of myself that i've
shut off and that was hard but but it
was
it was fun you know it was a really i
felt really lucky it's like a
it's like a a psychology a thing a
psychology an excuse to
do something psychologically deep you
know
yeah that's completely different listen
i
i'm curious what you paid to be in the
movie um yeah a lot
of what i sold all my game boys
you recently directed uh a feature i'm
curious
are you thinking about uh doing another
film soon
yeah i'm gonna do a movie with some
really cool people that
can't talk about it yet um but it'll be
probably announced soon but we're gonna
go
next spring um or our spring of 2022. so
that's gonna be really i'm really
excited for that
um but yeah i'm thank you i hope yeah
you guys have seen i think you did you
wrote a really nice review for cat in
the moon so i appreciated that
did you did you write this next one yeah
i wrote it i'm gonna be
directing it and then i'm i'm not
starring in and i'm but i'm co-acting in
it um
you know it's it's always a little
embarrassing to do all that stuff but
it's just these certain stories i just
want it told a certain way
so i completely understand obviously the
jumanji movies have been a little bit
what we call popular
are you a little surprised at the
popularity
yeah i mean yeah it's like a reboot to
have it explode like that it's crazy but
it's the rock i mean everybody wants to
see the rock and it's big
gorgeous muscles and being hilarious and
and um
yeah so i guess i wasn't i wasn't
surprised that people loved him so much
but i was surprised that so many people
went for the
both movies i just i just thought the
luck of that is just
one in a million i have to stop there
i'm just going to say congrats on
everything
and thank you so much